thank you all and after all these years
I think
[Music]
okay so I want to say thank you to the
Academy because of you the Academy got
the chance to stand here to challenge
myself to speak in front of so many
people here so thank you Academy's Thank
You Sean Denise and Hector for taking
care of us and firstly I like to thank
Lola and her both Belgian and Chinese
family part of them are here Lola and 15
could you maybe stand up Thank You Lola
Christine Patrick Justine Cammy after
you as well as I call them the Chinese
part usual ie leader and the union
leader shown lives alone and all the
last cousins without you the film would
never be made thank you and of course
I'd like to thank my lovely crew and so
supportive a alyssum a cinematographer
Dorota
my editor and my sandy Daniel pandava
and the colorist editor and the
extraordinary animator and sound design
for the interim video and either and
Nicholas but unfortunately they didn't
have chance to show the intro video but
I want to thank them because for their
great great efforts and hard work
I also want to thank everyone at my
school the national the Polish national
film school in wood especially my
artistic supervisors attack blood and
Andrea so nice the Polish version panty
GUI and Rio which are important College
the Russia of Sparta a Christian
montre su Castilla NAPLAN dating where
he the one who changed another yes
dimensional Nia Wong sunset just drop
you want and fill pot version open can
we adapt and now most importantly I want
to thank my mom my dad and me thank you
for your unconditional love and endless
support thank you she's any man
[Applause]
[Music]